das einheit der sogenannten aha regeln
zu denen auch das tragen einer maske
gehört kann bei einzelnen schülern zu
großen problemen führen machen masken
unsere kinder krank also wollen wir was
sonst wenn demonstriert die maße
betragen muss nicht tatsächlich
kopfschmerzen und haben würde
aber was alles passiert ist habe ich
hier so getreten in der bewusst als ich
hier in diesem bereich und dann war mir
sehr sehr schwindelig ich kann nicht
mehr ich aufstehen und dann muss ich
mich hinsetzen muss ich erst mal was
trinken und dann als ich dann halt
aufgestanden bin hab mich hat mein
freund gesehen ok ich muss mit der an
die frische luft haben ich nicht
wahrscheinlich gegangen bevor ich keiner
bin habe ich so ich weiß jetzt hat sich
angefühlt als besonders schwarzes und
meiner um so richtig nicht nur ein
gelaufen haben dann weiß ich nichts mehr
diese eltern machen sich zu recht große
sorgen um ihre kinder zu schützen
gehen sie juristisch gegen die korona
verordnungen vor
ich habe viele eltern die mich anrufen
weil es den kindern eben nicht schlecht
gehen weil sie seelisch schlecht geht
weil an den schulen dauer gelüftet wird
ja also die kinder frieren im unterricht
können sich nicht konzentrieren haben
kopfschmerzen haben auch panikattacken
auch manche meinen dann auch sehr viel
kommt noch mal ein bisschen aufs alter
drauf an
neben echten gesundheitlichen problemen
gibt es aber auch eine reihe von
vorurteilen und bedenken die gegen das
tragen von masken sprechen in der eu bis
3 oder das heißt ja rechtsstaatsprinzip
damals von unserer
verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip das heißt
alles staatliche handeln exekutive
legislative ist
dieses verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip
gebunden so wenn man das jetzt anfangen
zu prüfen braucht man zunächst werde man
prüfen einen legitimen zweck das wäre
der gesundheits- und bevölkerungsschutz
dann würde ich ihr konkret prüfen sind
diese masken geeignet um diesen
angestrebten erfolg überhaupt zu
erreichen als sie ihn zu fördern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren